coming up on his third season as a
starter for the Los Angeles Dodgers here
to talk about the the the revamped Major
League Baseball season and what that's
going to look like it's my friend and
all-star pitcher
mr. Walker Buehler
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
would you get a people we got a poisons
and what can it you can jump higher
anything right now oh wow huntin really
now now how much training goes into
training like a hunt dog I'm gonna send
it away Oh same way for like six months
no wait out of America or no no to that
breeds I call South Carolina so you sent
it there Huntsville maybe dude I turn
that Levasseur to Japan's you never come
back like a little ninja you know they
wouldn't know what ducks are dude but
he'd be able to sneak into somebody's
house at night ever hunt dog he'd be
able to use a sword you like dang that's
the only dog that can use a sword man
Walker Buehler you guys are back in
training camp right now what do you guys
what does baseball call it uh well I've
heard summer camp which is an
interesting one it sounds like yeah but
no I think kind of spring training 2.0
is what they're kind of going with and
so you were saying you had a place out
here in LA and then you had to get you
had to you were ready to come back for
the season right mhm and then you had to
just Nix it yeah so for us we kind of
get six eight month leases just trying
to find somewhere for the season and
then I got wrangled into a ten month
lease because I really wanted this place
and I was up in the hills and I was like
this is my last year on my first part of
my rookie deals like alright I'll just
get the cool ones and a little extra I'm
gonna splurge a little bit and then
we're not here for three months so no I
got lucky somebody lease it out and I
got to find another place but yeah we're
a little disappointed
dang and so the time at home were you
like uncertain up until the last minute
or is like is the players like who's
communicating with the excuse me who's
communicating with the players like
we're gonna do something we're not gonna
play we are like is there how does that
work for you guys yeah so we have
obviously we have our big players union
right but we have like a rep for each
team and of course I got thrown into
being our rep two weeks before baseball
ended up coming back so I jumped into
this stuff like way late for the Dodgers
yeah so it was JT and now I'm I'm our
rep but I've been kind of just sitting
back chillin waiting on
when we were gonna play and then two
weeks before everything kind of came
together it was like hey walk now you're
talking for us so a lot of group me so I
said hey what do you guys think yeah
it's uh it's pretty complicated all the
[ __ ] you know all the stuff that goes
into it that I didn't even really know
about and then it's like hey you're
right in the middle of it so it's been a
little bit of a learning curve kind of
huh oh for sure for sure
yeah and do what is what's gonna be
different about the season so the season
is happening mm-hmm and you guys are in
spring training summer camp 2.0 right
now and what's gonna be different about
the season first off they're telling us
that you can only have a certain amount
of guys in the dugout which is weird
because we all sit in there and hang out
and [ __ ] and whatever during the
games so now they're saying if you're
not playing you have to sit in the
stands so there are gonna be fancy looks
if they're gonna be us oh you should be
a lot of this change in a more relaxing
right I mean it's yeah it's odd I told I
talked to Kurt and I thought they also
said we can go home which is like not
something that has ever been okay so um
hey I'm I may never watch you throw live
all year he's what are you talking about
I said I'm just gonna sit in the pool
watch John oh because you wouldn't have
to be there because usually the bullpens
there and stuff you right the bullpen
will still be out there but us we'll
just starting pitchers usually sit right
there in the dugout and kind of hang out
so if we can leave damn it's almost like
you think you'll miss that part yeah you
know what's weird is in Asia Lee that's
like standard operating procedure for
them so they leave what like if they're
not pitching they're not there yeah they
go in during them you know during the
afternoon get their stuff done an hour
before the game they just head out but
we had a Korean guy hon Jin rue that he
like hated watching games cuz he'd never
done it it's her life and then he comes
to America and like expected to stay
forever dude I'm not kidding you that
guy would be out of the locker room
within five minutes of the last out I
don't even think our to the field I
think he just threw a bowl
no he's like I'm not even pay for this I
want to go to dinner that's crazy
I went to actually a baseball game one
time in Japan look yeah it's pretty cool
went to one in Japan and I went to one
in Cuba once Cuba
yeah I went to I was in this school like
this school program I've got to go
abroad and and one of the like things we
got to do when we were there was good at
baseball interesting yeah yeah I got I
got to play in Cuba for a week Wow
yeah so I guess they have some sports
diplomacy law or something like at that
time we were like the only Americans
ever allowed in there yeah and so we
went and we lost all five games so I was
really happy about this
well maybe subliminally I don't think
you really want to win over there right
but we did a good time it was fun dang
and do you notice anything different
like about do you notice anything
different about the way that they were
that they play Ernie yeah I will tell
you the big the weirdest thing that they
do so you know how like if you strike
somebody out they throw the ball around
mm-hmm and it just goes once the third
baseman to shortstop to second baseman
and they throw it back to the pitcher
that's how they do it here in u.s. yes
okay and Cuba they make 30 throws they
throw it to the catcher the pitch will
get it throw it back to the shortstop
the game's taking major league gets it
he throws it home plate yeah fan gets
the toss I mean it's wild yeah and the
games took like 30 minutes longer
because they're just flinging the ball
around after every strikeout Johnny
that's pretty wild
our one time actually because one of the
things I was doing I was trouble I went
to on this thing called semester at
scene it was like a school that guy was
on a ship and takes two different
countries when you're a student and so
we went to Hong Kong and so I remember
just walking around during the day and
play pick-up basketball games and stuff
and the thing that they do they're like
in that was different after somebody
scores they like run it back like
whoever gets out of the net runs it you
don't dribble it or pass it up if you've
run it up to the top of the top of the
key and then start the game again yeah
it was our to hood and they would kind
of frown on you like if you threw it up
there they would kind of throw it back
and you had like run it okay stop it was
like and it feels weird just to run with
a basketball you know yes you're playing
running back yeah yeah it feels like a
crime so but I remember that was like
the strangest thing did I remember that
was just like um like a sport in a
different country I don't think I've
ever heard that so with the dugout
saying in a regular game you know can
you go over to the other team's dugout
er no if you do that normally there's a
fight involved I don't know if you saw
last year there was a guy named Amir
Garrett who pitches for the Reds
he played basketball st. John so he's
big tall dude reliever for the Reds
right and they were res and Pirates had
this whole befall year he just ran
directly at their dugout one on 30
people I play with that catcher to Kyle
farmer he seemed like he's ready to
cause a little trouble to man
Georgia boy who he's been traded so much
huh
well we seems like that girl in the NBA
that everybody banging this so they came
to get him out of there and then he said
all right come on that's a bad boy I
think that one we got a slap look at
them all right yeah there's a little bit
man
so if you're on the mound right now
usually it seemed like the pitcher is
kind of the one that starts the brawl
yeah it usually boils down to somebody
getting hit so the pitcher is always
involved now me being a smaller guy we
we do rehearse my moves if anything like
that ever happens like what do you mean
like you rehearse your moves well
somebody's gonna run at me if I ever get
into one of these situations okay yeah
because you'll hit them on accident yes
okay and then so they'll come at you so
you have it kind of rehearse what to do
then right cuz I they're gonna be bigger
than me
right cuz I'm small right so we've
boiled down I either have to slowly
creep wait for the corner infielders to
come and get them for me right or I
gotta go with a dropkick I think it's a
sigh you know it's a it's a mass thing I
just can't yeah or you just fling the
glove that
it's been done before how do you here
move this a little closer if you don't
mind how do you so cuz your size like
how does your size compare to to some of
the pictures that are out there because
Kershaw is way taller than you yeah
Kersh is about two inches taller but
he's about 40 pounds heavier okay 80
pounds I'll give him the benefit right
good out there yeah I'm just I'm skinny
you know compared to most guys most guys
are pretty thick and just one of your
arms weigh more than the other one of
your arms or not you know I don't know I
think they're probably pretty close I
would imagine the right ones a little
bit bigger mm-hmm just cuz the extra
ligament in there so maybe a couple
ounces heavier because you what you got
an extra ligament put in yeah so I tore
the one but they left it and put a new
one in there so where do they get that
one from they cut it right on my wrist
and that time yeah that's okay so Tommy
John surgeries in the yeah so I think
you can see the scar here is right here
oh wow but they cut so if you go like
this and then move your finger up see
that in big line yeah that one but not
on this one cuz that's what they cut out
and put back in my elbow Wow yeah so uh
yeah because I always thought Tommy John
was the shoulder it's not no that's
Tommy John's Diavel labrum or rotator
cuff as a shoulder though that's a bad
deal it is yeah Tommy John they're like
ninety percent with now like you're
probably gonna be fine
labrum labrum so like 50 do you know if
you is there a certain like life
expectancy on those parts of a pitchers
body where you like okay like an almost
like an oil change ok at 3 years I got
to take it in for this and then at 9
years I got to take any bum yeah you
hope you never have them like Kirsch has
never had an elbow or anything like that
but once you have when they say you got
about eight years with that new ligament
and they'll have to do something to to
keep it going but yeah I'm on your five
on my new ones so we're hoping it'll
it'll you know exceed those those enough
do you feel different once you got it in
oh yeah I started throwing four or five
miles an hour harder no way oh yeah you
got 12 months of rehab so you just sit
there and lift and watch baseball and
play golf basically and then I started
was throwing away harder and I got to
the big leagues really quick after that
just because may became a lot easier to
use that in college I got it right after
I signed in the pros okay so because I
know you're out at you're from Kentucky
and that's where you live now also right
yeah and um and then you went to
Vanderbilt you know three years there
and then that's when you get into the
pros yep so you drafted after junior
season typically and you still come back
for your senior season no no no no so I
never graduated none of that I didn't
graduate I'd only played three years got
drafted then you move on okay
and now when you get drafted a lot of
times it's like it seems like these guys
where did you get drafted at what do you
mean like you get drafted it a certain
picks right yeah so I was a 24th pick
okay but which for most people would be
a really cool thing or first-round pick
I was a third guy on our team would get
drafted so it was kind of like I was
happy but I was also a little you know
pissed right but you get a little pissed
all the time but a lot of stuff though
yeah I'm kind of really angry that way
yeah you know you get that fire in you a
little bit yeah a little jealous a
little a little competitive chip on your
shoulder yeah you have to be I always
tell everyone my dad's like five foot
eight yeah I was like one of the only
things he ever gave me was my Napoleon
complex right I'm almost 60
I feel like I'm about five foot four
that's funny it's like this guy has the
tallest Napoleon complex we've ever seen
borderline I think it's it's up there
probably and now and what did your dad
you what would your dad do for work so
he works
Bank of America kind of boring
commercial lending stuff but yeah he
does yeah he actually just moved to
Irvine so we're really excited to have
him out here so I'll get to see him
where he's been in Colorado the past few
years so and what about your mom my
mom's an attorney in Lexington around
little own little law firm there and and
does all that stuff but she used to tell
him my favorite thing was she would tell
me a case when I was like six years old
and I would tell her what I think it was
worth and I'd be with this like 30 grand
every time yeah they left this gauze in
this woman I'm like 1.7 not 1.6 yeah
so that's 4,800 mile yeah that's why I
had some weird knack for it but I always
said that's probably what I would do if
I didn't play but I'm kind of glad I
don't have to do that [ __ ] yeah did you
um did you uh tell me a little bit more
about some of the new rules that are
gonna be going on okay so they're saying
we can't spit number one so you watch a
baseball game you you know people spit
cuz it
yeah that's going to be interesting
they're saying instead of spinning we're
gonna have a wet rag in our back pocket
so we can touch that and then go to the
ball because you need a little moisture
sometimes so we'll see how long that one
lasts I think obviously the dugout stuff
because someone's gonna spin immediately
just by Nature yeah you don't even know
you do it yeah you know you just spit is
it a penalty if you spit or this game be
like somebody saying hey I think they
can find you know yeah buying you I
don't understand why it would be a
financial thing I think it's a bacteria
in the air they believe I also know that
if you hit a ground ball and more than
two guys hit touch the ball so you threw
it
third baseman catches it throws the
first baseman three guys touch it gotta
get a new ball oh yeah
it's gonna be a while the unharmed
blowtrotters and so are you concerned
about how um and now hold on there's
more rules though - I read one that
there is because I didn't know about
these so but there's one where if you
guys you guys aren't gonna bad anymore
correct
so the pitchers will no longer bat yes
which is a good thing bad thing it's all
it's all good and bad because I like to
hit but we all suck okay
so there's there's two pitchers maybe
they can actually really hit I don't
have any of them no offense to Kirsch or
any of those guys none of our guys okay
so but now I got to face another actual
hitter I don't get to face myself which
is kind of a freebie a lot of the time
so yeah so a lot of those guys in
because the American League they have
they have the D H already so they have
the the pitcher never bats right so they
have nine professional hitters so they
have a so American league pitchers it's
harder for them to get a no-hitter for
sure 100%
dang it's not easy regardless right
easier in the National League probably
okay so I'm just thinking about these
rules this is so insane dude I almost
feel like now I'm at the rodeo and it's
almost like we're not playing baseball
just playing like wiffle ball but okay
so now also there's a rule if you guys
go to
extra innings that they're gonna put
someone on second base yeah
so that that they've been doing that the
Meyer leagues for a long time okay kind
of testing it out it'll JT actually came
out and said he won at Home Run Derby
and they see snow Justin Turner our
third baseman big red beard guy okay he
said he wants a home run derby to break
the break the extra innings which I love
I think it'd be hysterical at the end of
the camera but I'll tired hit homer and
that's what the X ratings really are
because everybody wants to hit the
walk-off so everyone just crazy at home
runs all the time in extra
anyway so they've done this rule at the
guy in second forever in the minor
leagues trying to figure it out and now
we're gonna give it a go in the big
leagues I guess but it'll be interesting
do you have any thought yeah like what
are your thoughts on it
I like leave never like had to start an
inning that I didn't let somebody on
base and they just stuck somebody out
there but they be pressure right out the
gate cuz that guy's already there yeah
and then there's like a million
different strategies you know you can
bond or whatever to try and get him
two-thirds we can score easier and it
might be cool it might be a way for a
pitcher finally get back in the batter's
box though because pitchers are pretty
pretty good bunters typically and but
but you ought but even if your team
doesn't get to bat first you still get
the bottom of that inning right yeah
yeah yeah yeah cuz that almost seems
like man you could easily get the yeah
maybe it'll make it a little more
exciting it might because sometimes
these games just go on forever yeah we
had that World Series game two years ago
went 17 innings and I threw the first
seven of it I was at the ballpark long
or not playing that was and I threw the
ball really good it was just took
forever we played should I got home at
like 3:00 in the morning that's there
and when the game started like a so
whenever it gets into late innings guys
are just trying to hit that walk-off
yeah why no it's just a beautiful thing
to see on this 14 yeah I think so it's
it's very funny how it happens in the in
the in extra innings like everyone
either punches out or Hetzel hits the
homer
you know but sometimes that's why they
go so long oh I'd hit that home have to
so you can't go over to the dugout for
anything what if they tell the buddy
something can you run over there and
tell him something if he's another team
you know I don't know if they're gonna
let us have phones walkie-talkies for
income but even before that like last
like say last season you wanted to tell
the buddy something oh yeah we just sit
there and [ __ ] the whole time but in
the other dugout I mean
okay nothing even if it's your buddy no
you can't and you know there's certain
times where it's okay to like go say
what's up and then there's certain times
that it's not so I can batting practice
and stuff sometimes will linger out
there and talk to the other team but no
after a certain point there's there's
nothing we've got a question here from a
young fella right here and this might be
Kron Gracie right here this guy how do
you fill the whole sign ceiling scandal
that's been going on and you think that
is uh it's gonna affect in any way or
shape the way that you guys played
baseball disease or is it gonna be the
same thank you for anything
gonnigan gang game from Porto Rico man
the Lima the science and so you do you
know much about this or no I know that
Houston got in trouble Reyes yeah so
what's interesting is they were doing
all this [ __ ] live so they'd know what
was coming before it even came right
wouldn't that's unfair right which we're
all against that a lot of got you know
we do scouting and things like that that
you can push a limit and we all kind of
know what that limit is and they were
past it so you know and then the Red Sox
got bang they weren't doing anything
near what what Houston was doing so
Houston was really what they were they
were knowing what the signs were mm-hmm
and then communicating ways to
communicate it yeah they were hitting on
the wall was that stuff real or do you
think a lot of that spin exact I mean
the videos seem to seem to really say
that that was what was going on I wasn't
on the team really at that point I had
been in the big leagues but I didn't
make the place their postseason roster
so I wasn't there but from everything I
had heard I think it was it was pretty
legit that they were they were doing
something and so say if something like
that is going on who knows about it on
the team would everybody know or would
just that kind of stuffs obviously gonna
be related to the pitchers and catchers
more than anybody because they're doing
the signs mm-hmm
but everyone's gonna know that stuff
kind of traveled like wildfire I guess
possibly wearing buzzers too yeah that
was the rumor I don't think that one was
ever proven but you know I think when
you do one thing you caught four
one thing everybody can say you could do
a million different things and it's kind
of hard not to not to at least think it
could happen but because once you start
also taking advantage of the rules or
bending I man you know once you get one
way to do it it's easy to be like oh I
can also probably do press way right and
Jose Altuve after he hit that walk-off
and they like they all rushed him at the
mound at the time I was like oh that was
adorable cuz he's like don't rip my
shirt my wife will be mad at me but it
seemed like after it was cuz it would
uncover its buzzers conspiracy theories
are great yeah it seemed pretty lot
possible yeah I mean you know it is what
it is obviously we were in the locker
room or in their locker room and knew
what was going on but but if something
like that was going on on a team right
say it's going on the even on your it
was going on and just hypothetical on a
team that your own wouldn't with
somebody on the team what is there a
code in there where it's like this is
how we do is it's just this is our we do
it this year do you think somebody would
raise their hand or with that person
raise your hand you like dude chill the
[ __ ] out yes there's some sort of
there's some sort of like clubhouse
security I guess where everything kind
of a lot of stuff stays in there and and
shouldn't go anywhere so leave somebody
in your own team told told on you about
it like there'd be problems I think but
yeah I think if it's hoping you win I
think everyone's gonna know on the team
and everyone's gonna be involved
personally that would be my my guess huh
it's an interesting it's an interesting
deal do you do pitchers get are you when
you go out there to play and last year
you had your first all-star season okay
congrats man thank you when you go out
there to play are you playing okay I'm
gonna beat this other pitcher I'm gonna
beat this team like what is the pitchers
kind of motivation or my own even
motivation but who is he who are you
against yeah I think I think it's the
other team is the big thing but when you
face guys that you like grown up
watching there's a little bit of like
[ __ ] like I'm facing Max Scherzer today
yeah and I think for me it was always
like oh I get to hit against him and
just see what this is all about that's
gone but no I think most the time it's
the other team and the
is kind of secondary unless it's like a
certain guys okay so when you're
pitching in if it's a certain picture up
there then you might feel like oh this
is kind of exciting right like for you
it'd be I think like four you'd be like
oh I'm getting more views on this
podcast right if we had the same guest
who's did more it would be more
important you know what I'm saying yeah
your mom's also win probably but yeah
now I see what you're saying okay and if
a pitcher gets up there so it's kind of
cool say if there's if there's a great
pitcher it's kind of cool for you to be
able to bat because you get to bat
against him yeah because you've watched
it on ESPN your whole life right so
you're like oh like why can't these guys
hit this and then he throws you that one
pitcher you're like oh now I get get one
edition Scherzer was like that for me
really oh yeah what was it about is well
he threw me a fast one the first one
look wasn't super hard and then a couple
more pitches he threw me another fast
one I didn't even see it was so firm I
guess he just kind of like laid off one
and then threw one hard I think I was
like laughing walk it off no chance yeah
it seems here we got a kid right here
that has a question dole shirt yeah baby
Bob you know what up the Oh what up
Walker I just had a quick question for
Walker when I'm watching baseball
there's a couple guys I kind of key in
on wanting to watch guys like yourself
Jack Flaherty Max Scherzer guys that are
just Bulldogs on the mound I was
wondering if Walker had any guys that he
likes to watch whether it's starting
pitchers or position players but guys
that he just enjoys watching them do
their thing out there on the ball field
anyway hope you guys are having a good
day and Theo gang gang thanks bro nice
guy where did that come from
gang gang yeah I don't know really it
was before my time here yeah just been
rolling up yeah I don't really know man
but people come to sign off on the end
we gotta get Walker some slides yeah we
got to get you some slides man I'll rock
those awesome all right hey our trainers
get so mad because I just watch
Instagram videos all the time I like
working on my arm and they just hear all
these the oh [ __ ]
like look I'm not gonna Goodyear when I
first days back like a couple days ago I
was watching [ __ ] there's like up
dealers back well I think the first time
you say you heard it Bobby all of us the
we're talking about Bryce Harper I've
been combing my hair with cocaine so we
always get these new interns sorry we'll
get to your question we always get these
new interns and I show them there's one
you start about eating pineapple and
somebody's grandmother's they're like
yeah welcome the caption is teamö them
chunks I think Oh get a job with the
Marlins after getting really shot e over
you but know one of the guys he
mentioned Jack Flaherty's a buddy of
mine and we pitch against each other
twice and and back in the minor leagues
too so he's probably one of my favorite
guys to watch now yeah yeah he's from
out here somewhere I think it went to
harvard-westlake mmm that's a fancy
school oh yeah yeah I got three guys in
the big leagues now that we're all high
school teammates oh yes Wow I was like
is stacked bro they have a really
stacked squad um so wow that's so
interesting
easier as a pitcher when you get up
there too bad against a pitcher it would
seem like oh well you know what they're
doing yeah you know I I think my career
batting errors under a hundred so I
don't think I have any any way to say
it's easy
kind of terrible but you know it's fine
it was part of the game I guess it's sad
even walking up there sometimes with the
bat like is it certain guys you're
absolutely because there's a viewer
you're like oh this is real sad like why
would they do this is almost like when
they shoot the heavy and then stuff
Vande kind of feel like a gladiator but
you're like the guy without a sword yeah
yeah let's see what this couch the
notebook is gonna do over here damn
you can't act like you don't have a
chance no so a real hitter walks up and
they're like all right I'm trying to hit
this ball hard I want to try and sit on
it I just walk up there and try and see
as many pitches like like my goal is to
foul balls off most the time yeah yeah
because that counts on this video guys
well yeah hell yeah if you see six
pitches you've done like a really good
thing
Wow oh yeah instead of just three right
down the middle Galahad over here and so
you can't tell though when a pitch
leaves a pitcher it's the same you are
you then not a pitcher once you're
batting it I mean I know that you know
technically you're still a pitcher and
you're batting but do you have any any
insight as to what's gonna happen yeah I
was actually a really bad hitter in high
school because I would like give these
other guys credit Furla all right if
that was me pitching I'm like looking
for this pitch like I would do this and
they would never do it it's like
blackjack yeah you think like poker or
whatever like I had this hand I did and
they were terrible wow it's so I throw a
slider right here and they just throw me
fastball right down the middle I'd miss
him but it was it was just because they
were a bad picture yeah and I was
overthinking it dang dude that's so
crazy man it seems like it is
man I'm where the first time I ever got
up to bat man they had this and I was
horrible at it I mean I remember one
time they put us out there I'm reading
psychedelic mushrooms I'm out yeah wait
dude we had right and double right on
our team didn't I always had a bike
double right back back right oh dude and
one time I end up working at the
snowball stand for two innings it was
like man but the coach said it still
counted you know right we had to play
two innings right yeah that was the that
was the saddest I was the worst get in
there I had an appendectomy in my
appendix burst when I was a kid lapping
the bases really between two bases so I
hit the ground man you know cuz I
couldn't I'd you out or no uh they'd
give you the base I don't know what
happened to coach was furious he's like
frog call me after this back and you can
still call kids in a buffer you know
he's like Ron MF or run you know and I
was just like squealing is it okay yeah
can I mean I couldn't I know I was gone
and he came and dragging about both my
arms from
third - home dude and we got the run but
it was like dude gave a [ __ ] he was
horrible we're playing at the American
Legion it's just men you doing it
slaughter oh yeah everybody there's a
Vietnam veteran do getting sunburned
waiting for their check it was just
Rocky so any other any other
expectations you have going into the
season does it feel like going into a
regular season like absolutely not okay
it can't we've been sitting at home for
three months you know I mean so I don't
know well I hope we get all our games in
that'd be the biggest thing in the
playoffs and all that but with all the
new kovetz around I get you know I don't
know what's gonna happen yeah
and they are planning on traveling dead
yeah so what they did normally we play
every national team so we go to the East
Coast back and forth all the time which
sucks because we get screwed on the time
stuff but we're only playing I think
we're only playing like the the NL West
so our division and the AOS so we're
kind of staying out here which will be
nice travel wise yeah you know what I
mean instead of six hours flight six
hour flights to Washington so that's so
they're making it easy that way there'll
be nobody in the stands correct what do
you think like is that kind of is
everybody still gonna care about the
game as much it takes some of the ego
out of it almost yeah it takes some of
the energy out of it for sure you know
like I think a lot of teams talked about
buying crowd noise or pumping crowd
noise in there so it feels a little bit
oh yeah more like I saw in Korea they're
using sex dolls you understand yeah some
teams I heard or you can pay 50 bucks
and get a cardboard cutout of yourself
put in the stadium which is kind of
interesting
yeah it's not a bad idea no but they're
doing some they're doing some wacky
stuff especially over there in Korea Wow
yes those were sex dolls cheering on a
South Korean soccer team I think they
got in trouble for that why some loser
takes our ha and they're wearing masks
it's an interesting - yeah and there's
six feet of our yeah that's an
interesting one Wow someone social-media
go back up to the top if you don't mind
Nick over the weekend mannequins were
placed in the stands for a match against
wangju FC someone superiority that
telltale signs business logos for sex
toy marketers tried to add some funny
says finding the no spectator match I
like it kind of I love the idea of
having somebody be able to send a
pitcher in or like themselves put in the
stands like for a certain like I said
you can do that as a gift to somebody
yeah you know like you're there yeah
happy birthday we threw in Conger
station and maybe somebody it doesn't
want to be there's like Grandma you know
imagine open that for Christmas it just
says you have a cardboard cutout yeah
you never get to see it but you might
get one of those stars it's like
somebody buys a star like oh thanks some
sea otter yeah I have to go outdoors at
night I live in a dangerous neighborhood
we doesn't make land it today's episode
is brought to you by better help you
know it's not anything new to know that
people need help if you see somebody in
in me and they're trying to do something
they can't do it then they need help and
that's what better help does but it does
it for the inside of your body inside of
your head in your brain better help will
assess your mental health needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist I've used better
help I even pulled over on the side of
the road one time and used him however
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log in anytime and send a message to
your counselor there's also different
ways you can have a counselor you can do
it over text you can do it on the phone
you can do it over FaceTime you could do
it on your laptop but it just makes it a
different way where if you don't want to
go down to this the place that's in your
town or in your neighborhood maybe your
friend's wife is the counselor or
something you don't want to do that but
you want to talk to somebody you got
things you want to say this is a way to
do it
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today and that's true visit
better help.com slash Theo
that's btter heelp dot-com / t heo and
you will get 10% off your first month
that's right
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
that's better help calm / th e oh thank
you for supporting yourself and for
supporting the podcast do you have car
insurance well if you don't then you're
part of the problem but if you do well
either way just know that it's been
reported that Americans are overpaying
on car insurance
by over 21 billion dollars but searching
for a better deal can take hours and
typically results in a barrage of
unwanted spam calls
yep you you go to a site next you know
they call and their kids are calling you
know you got Larry insurance or you know
a lot Eastside instead on Singh they
hitting you up but things have changed
now thanks to the zebra comm the zebra
dot-com is the nation's leading car
insurance comparison site because it's
the only place you can compare quotes
side-by-side from over 100 providers and
choose the best for you in 90 seconds or
less plus they will never sell your
information to the spammers just answer
a few questions on a simple fast form
and they find you the best rates and
coverage in your state TechCrunch calls
the zebra kayak for auto insurance the
best part it's completely free you can
save up to six hundred and seventy
dollars a year using the zebra comm and
how much can you save on car insurance
and home insurance well go today and
start saving at the zebra dot-com / th
EO that's the zebra dot-com / th EO
spelled th e ze b r a.com slash th e o i
am using progressive and i know that i'm
using i'm paying too much so i'm going
to check it
and see what I can do thank you guys for
supporting the podcast so yeah I'm
trying to think of anything else that
will be different at that so there'll be
no snacks cuz nobody's mind I'm all
that's gonna be down you know it's just
gonna be solely to make sure that they
have a season probably to keep the
flagship of the whole business going
correct which is pretty important oh
yeah yeah you know I think one of the
big things have been the owners come out
saying we're not gonna make it we're not
making money we're gonna lose money but
everybody's franchises keep going up so
these owners yeah they're not marrying
in cash right but they can sell this
thing for X amount more every year that
they keep it so you know we're excited
to get back out there and play obviously
and and you know at least people can
watch this at home which would be fine
now are you in the end were you excited
like yes we're gonna get to play we're
gonna get to do we're gonna get to do
something yeah all of us I think are
there's a few guys that have opted out
of it which I think if you have family
and stuff I think that's a that's a
decision that you have to really like
stare down I'm ready go I'm excited they
have a Latino friend of mine named Rudy
and he's owned aids not just Latinos
specifically Mexican and he works at
this he's like the manager at this cafe
that I go to all the time I neighborhood
and he loves you and he's like oh good
guy that got local that's how he always
says time I go in there you don't even
say your name anymore he's just like oh
that guy had a couple any time a little
bit Asian unfortunately my accents are
not good my rookie are two to live TV
f-bombs we've tried to try to curtail
those yeah it's a very family-friendly
but but do you think that chip wears
that chip on your shoulder come from man
cuz you definitely like you have an
intensity about you that I think like
when I first met you I was like wow just
cuz your size and I mean you're you know
you're bigger than me but then I am but
and this was the same way when I met
drew brees are like wow I this is not
exactly who I expected maybe if I
thought these days of a major league
player yeah I think as I said earlier
Napoleon complex is for sure part of it
but I think the other thing was being
small I played a little football I was
always too scared I think when I play
baseball it's like oh I'm the smallest
one but I'm
not to be scared of this you're gonna
hurt me you know and so I think you take
that little fear and turn it somewhere
else so you can kind of function I guess
and as the stakes get higher I think it
just amplifies it for me at least where
I get a little more you know a little
more jazz juiced-up
yeah when you're pitching do you is
there a pitch like does the catcher who
gets to pick what pitch throw you throw
the catcher are you so the catcher gives
the way they explain that catcher gives
you a suggestion and you agree to that
suggestion 95% time we have a whole big
meeting that's like 30 30 minutes on
going over every hitter and and what we
want to do before the game so we kind of
know like at least out there I don't
have to think as much I told them what I
think now they kind of just remind me
and then I throw that pitch okay but my
rookie here we had a really veteran
catcher so couldn't really shake them
off you can't really say no really yeah
certain guys 15 Mike Piazza or something
sitting out that you'd probably go along
with what he says yeah Wow because he's
seen these batters so many times right
and you and those the assumption is that
he's been there longer so he knows what
you're doing better than you do you know
now if you throw a pitch that they
choose it it's also kind of nice to you
because then if it gets rocked you have
somebody to blame it on right right
right
you know it's that's an inch the worst
possible scenario is you shake the guy
off three times and throw it then he
hits a home run because then the catcher
just says listen dumbass I told you you
know yeah that's actually exactly what
they will say so that so that
relationship between catch our pitcher
and catcher is pretty it's pretty severe
Wow really super trusting you know you
have to be or else you're gonna freak
yourself out the whole time and do you
have does every pitcher have every same
pitch as everybody else do some pictures
have know everybody's got different
different stuff and even we all call
certain things the same thing and they
act completely different it's just kind
of the way you are you know I mean it's
like how you run or how you talk it just
oh I throw a slider and mine moves like
this and there's moves like this and
like like your boy Clevenger yeah and I
throw very similar stuff change up I
don't his stuff is bigger mine's kind of
harder it's just they're all different
little variations he's a little more
flashy or too
had it up oh dude wild yeah oh he tried
to send me a unicorn egg one time yeah
he's got yeah that's not surprise me man
he definitely did he pulled a seashell
out of his hair one time and I listened
to it bro and it totally the future
whole story but then he made me give it
back to him you know yeah that's just so
he yeah we saw him we're in Phoenix
eating breakfast or lunch or something I
saw his shorts were about halfway down
those legs we have tied I tanked up on
all his boys dressed exactly the same
I've never met the guy I wanted to sell
that's my Clevenger oh that it makes a
lot more sense now I think he's a flower
on his glove he's one of a kind ood he
told me he was trying to uh he told me
his glove was vegan and I was like
that's a made of leather too yeah but
yeah man he's one of a kind man um how
much does some of the pictures I noticed
like even microphone of the guys who
their leg movements will be different
how much are you allowed to do there
before it's like considered a type of
trickery or something if there's nobody
on nobody on base mm-hmm you can
basically do whatever you want Wow
basically there's some rules if you've
heard of a Bock yeah bulk is so that's
when you're creating deception in an
illegal fashion that's what a Bock is
okay so is that shady to do if you
bought it just sucks they gonna freebase
okay so they got a man on third and Bock
they score they don't have to touch it
they don't have to touch the ball
nothing they just walk home Wow so
that's if you come everybody gets a free
base yeah no matter where they are oh
yeah oh it sucks have you ever lost a
game on a Balkan before no my high
school loss I was in eighth grade going
to watch our varsity team I was like so
excited they lost on a walk-off Bock
that was tough to watch you seniors last
game guy [ __ ] up one time and games
over
season's over so what constitutes a balk
like what do you have to do when you're
on the mound there's a few things so
when you get your sign you come you have
to stop so your body has to fully stop
before you pitch so when you're young
you just kind of get it and throw it now
you have to get it pause and then throw
that's probably the most common one
mm-hmm
there's some certain pickoff moves you
have to like disengage the rubber all
these kind of boring rules but okay
you've just learned the normal way and
then like you Bach a lot when you're
young guys you don't know what you can
and can't do
okay yeah probably once you get called
for it then you start to really like
okay I've got a malfunction here the
weirdest one I've seen guy just dropped
the ball on the mat if you drop the ball
while you're touching the rubber to balk
oh wow
is this an accident yeah Cena got
bringing it to his you know bringing it
down and he hit his leg dropped it buck
that's course would you ever how much
pride is in it where say if you're not
doing well out there you're just having
a game where it's not you're going your
way
would you take yourself out of the game
ever Wow absolutely so there is a point
in every game where it's all about
preservation of the bullpen cuz the
bullpen super super important if you're
getting crushed you just try and like
survive as long as you can oh because
you want that to save the bullpen fresh
fruit in other games yeah I said yeah so
guys don't have to cover you you know I
mean you want it so I got killed in
Atlanta my first playoff start first
inning goes great second inning I walked
a pitcher to force a run in which is as
embarrassing as it gets
not even I didn't even throw a pitch
close my first playoff game we're down
one nothing like alright there are three
straight balls I get this on Instagram
people send it to me just for fun all
the time the fourth one
it was a ball umpire calls it a strike
next pitch mucuna hits a grand slam
we're not five nothing huh and at that
point I ended up throwing three more
innings gave up no more runs but we were
gonna lose probably but those three
innings safe three innings at one of our
other guys didn't have to throw so it
also gives you a little bit of
redemption then yeah a little bit of
like listen I I screwed this one up
pretty good but at least I kind of I'm
doing my best to help us out a little
right mmm it'd be like if you bombed
mm-hmm if you went on bombed which I'm
sure happens mmm at least you finish
your 10 minutes right instead of oh [ __ ]
a minute - this is going really poorly
so now my back up now the guy after me
has to do my eight minutes as well as
right in yeah so you want to try and at
least just get there even if it sucks
for you yeah damn is it real and bit
like is the feeling when you're out
there like like is it once if it starts
going bad like saying that game okay so
it starts going to start off bad but you
were able to get it back on
like does it feel like you lose your
confidence like what does it feel like
it just feels like everyone in the world
staring at you telling you that you suck
you know and even though you don't and
you know you don't you know you know
that you go home after that game you
obviously don't get food because there's
too many people that could see you yeah
right
so you get a room service and whoever
brings a room service if they'll smile
and you think they're just laughing at
you they're not they're just being nice
they just want that five dollar tip that
is driving off a salad right you're like
God that guy [ __ ] he's must be a UH
he must be a Cardinals fan yeah you also
sometimes will change your whole diet
for about twelve hours after you get
beat like that you just like you eat
another salad Otis or change it I think
in water bottles yeah because you think
I might as I [ __ ] something up along the
way that that led me to get killed so
well so there's almost like that taboo
element like you're like how do I
because you've been doing well and how
do I solve this something's going off
here what have I done
yeah karmic a lot of karma elements and
in baseball the whole superstition and
all that stuff now what's harder then so
say you're having a tough game yeah you
know you're having a tough game and you
know you feel everybody staring at you
is it better when you're in that dugout
then when the team's batting at least is
there some like respite or is that
hellish to because it that's when your
heads going nuts when you're out there
it's kind of right fastball we'll try
this one again it's already sucks but
we'll give it a shot when you're sitting
in the dugout and you're just like
looking around everybody's we're down
sixteen everybody and you're always by
yourself too when the cameras posted
Hitler is losing he's always by himself
over there and he's pissed
who did this this is my fault damn
that's heavy man sucks yeah so you have
a contract now mhm and then what happens
so how long does a rookie contract is
there a year imagine so you become a
free agent after six full services
information man it's just you know stuff
I think it's interesting because I think
people probably know the least about
baseball contracts of any of them like
when somebody Ziya Williamson gets
drafted yeah everyone knows how long he
has to be a pelican and what he's gonna
make and issued nobody knows [ __ ] about
us yeah we have to play six full seasons
in the big leagues so 172 days is a full
season
so if you don't whatever six times 172
is you have to have that many days in
the big leagues to be a free agent after
three years you get arbitration okay
it's like Clevenger's in arbitration I'm
next year will be an arbitration so I'm
on my last year in my three years okay
so once you get into arbitration then
what what does that mean then it's you
versus the team and an arbitrator and
your agent you need to go out a nudey
and you basically argue what you're
worth so the team will sit there and
tell you to your face how bad you suck
right and you'll tell them how great you
are right and then the guy it'll tell
you here's where we're at
okay huh interesting so after this next
year you'll be able to go in arbitration
yeah so this is a big season for you in
some ways that third season is a big
season for guys because they want to do
well that's easy yeah you have to
it's called up they call it a platform
year so this is like the worst season
you could get hurt that's what I'm gonna
Corey Seager got hurt in its third year
he did primate half of what he would
have if he would have played hell huh
and but also it's interesting because
this season counts as a season right
this upcoming so I wonder if they'll
really put as much value it's almost
like well they still just go off of lash
what's a double-edged sword right
because if you do great they can say you
wouldn't sustain that and if you do
terrible they can say you were terrible
right but are you well I couldn't
sustain the shitty part either you know
but so in the end it's gonna be the same
you're gonna say one thing and it yeah
yeah everything I mean everything counts
but yes just business yes what about
some of these guys so you go up against
a guy like are there pictures where
you're like okay I'm excited about this
duel today like do you feel like it's
this is gonna be a real pitchers game do
you feel well you don't ever feel like
any more gonna be hitters games because
you don't want that team to be hit yeah
can't we just want us to hit right I
don't want them to at all Jack flirty
and I have had too good we both were
really well against each other we just
got lucky and scored a couple of runs so
Scherzer and I had a couple good games
at pitch against Gerrit Cole which was
cool the playoffs really get like that
that's when it that's when it really is
like when the matchups are really that
good yeah because it's all over social
media and it's like we're the only 100%
starter right like the manager could
flip the lineup if they felt like it
right
but the media knows it's Buehler versus
Strasbourg tomorrow and that's
everywhere so yeah I gotta beat him yeah
that's I think it's a little more like
that I think here's a question I hear
from someone my question for Walker is
who's the hardest hitter you've had to
face so far see I like this black
Charlie Blackmon is the guy that has the
best numbers off me in my career got
hair like yours really I don't know if
you want to pull up a picture this guy's
a good player though I'll [ __ ] hit off
his head plays out in Denver there you
go Oh does he oh yeah look at the Hat
here Matthew and Brian Wilson a little
bit a run Wilson oh yeah see I think if
you threw a little beard we could get a
mic chiesa MMA fighter who's that
michael Chiesa huh there was he looks
like that UFC fire that one this past
week to a big heavyweight oh yeah Tanner
bow sir
yeah the Canadian do I didn't see that
fight I really gotten into that stuff
since uh since its quarantine it's been
like the only thing what I was saying
about this thing about you guys the
other day when I was thing about
baseball was like man if you guys get
just coming back and being there for
people right now is gonna be huge
because people want to watch anything
yeah they want to watch some competition
you can't even get there's no fresh
television shows but as everything
they're put on shitty televisions really
weren't gonna pick up right enough -
yeah I mean have like dodgeball it like
you know it's getting real bad rumors
it's just people just sharing remembers
as quick as they can
I mean it's hitting really really
limited out there like a cross between
cops and cheaters yeah dude cheaters
used to be good I think I think there's
a little before my time to be honest
with you yeah might have been I like it
I remember watching I was like 12 and be
like this is so old dude the best
cheaters with written the guy I bust
somebody got a boat and the guy stands
up just tough to watch I met that guy at
a wine function out here now he was like
yeah man that was a tough episode which
guy the guy who stabbed him or the host
the guy who got stabbed yeah pretty cool
that's my favorite thing about LA man
you
the toughest dude I met oh yeah let me
see if we can see that stabbing launched
off
yeah you're gonna rest it at sea - huh
yeah police that's a weird thing what um
now there's offseason stuff you can't do
right there's or is it is it for you or
not yeah I mean I think kind of the
obvious stuff skiing stuff like that we
can't do and you can't do it at all well
you can but if you break your collarbone
your contracts gone right you know
really risky I love to ski and stuff but
you can't do it yes chemo yeah some
people have some weird stuff in their
country if her guys aren't a lot of wear
flip-flops you know because they're bad
ankles the team will put that in that
contract like no no no flip-flops for
you but yeah Golf is even supposed to
not be allowed any to being skiing
snowboarding on none of that show so do
you feel lemonade it everywhere your
contractor no you just kind of know that
those are the rules in the a of the the
business done man yeah I mean you sign
it you can't not sign the contract right
so yeah I mean I'd like to go ski but
you just can't do it yeah um do you
think you guys love the opportunity to
bring in new fans with the games go with
the game starting up um they said that
at UFC I was listening the other day I
think it was it was on kale saunas
podcast but that they brought in a
hundred thousand new fans a hundred
thousand people watched yes all right
UFC for the first time really this past
week of fights yeah yeah that wouldn't
that doesn't surprise me at all you know
I think they did a really good job
actually being the first you know what I
mean I think they probably have the
bread the most controllable environment
though because you have the least amount
of people in the locker room probably so
I think they did a good job of like
taking advantage of it I think more so
our fans are like gonna be happy that
we're back I guess right oh yeah I mean
hopefully everybody watches and you know
we're getting back before the NBA so
it's maybe get some of those fans a
little bit waiting for for them to come
back but do you um do you think so you
know it will be interesting is they
should have more focus and information
maybe about you guys the players because
they're not gonna be focusing on the
stand you know there won't be anything
really to look at in the stands right
right yeah yeah they're probably have an
extra 20 minutes a game to fill you know
just a
you have seen good fights in San
Francisco by the way my home plate yeah
this woman just smoked this guy pretty
cool stuff dude I was I'll tell you
before you were a Dodger I was high on
cocaine this is when I was using drugs
and I was high on cocaine at the Dodgers
game dude and I sat up in the top bro
dude the nosebleeds literally and the
nosebleeds I think are also a gang
that's up there as well literally a gang
called the nosebleeds up there and there
was one dude man I was so sketched out
there's one guy the whole time is
threatening to kill me but I think he
knows I'm I mean he keeps saying man I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you papa and then
there's another kind of sell me more
drugs it was angel in the devil actually
and he been anybody there I could have
been home man seemed like so like two
Devils yeah yeah double Devils man I
could have been at a Raiders game but it
dude I remember it being for all I was
like please this and then every time
there was a foul ball or any time the
ball hit the bat I thought it was coming
right at me have to yeah that'll happen
I think you know altitude up there - hey
you guys play it one of the biggest
stadiums don't you yeah it's gigantic
that was the one thing I remember the
most from my debut was like you never
really know how it's gonna feel you know
you run out there and you're all tired
from running and adrenaline you look up
and the stadium seems like it goes on
forever and you just I it's so weird to
me how big they built these things here
we got a young fella right here twins
fan what up yo what up Walker this is
Noah from North Dakota
Minnesota's neighbor if you didn't know
we didn't North Dakota was a state um
I've got a quick question regarding a
specific mo B stadium I know that you
play the Rockies often being in the NL
West and you had 16 K's on them last
year at home but does your approach
change when you're going into crews
field the pitch in Colorado
due to that high altitude you looking
for more ground balls you pitch around
people more often so let me know gang
game
good luck in your modified season yeah
like that nice nice guy a lot of nice
people man um yeah what is it Coors
Field sucks so the ball acts completely
different it flies a lot further when
they hit it so you know I think every
time at Pitzer I just come up with some
new thing in my head it makes me think I
can survive and so it's almost more
about survival there so that's not the
kind of place you think I can probably
get a no-hitter out here today oh no mo
who was big asian pitcher for us yeah
back in the day he threw a no-hitter
there though Wow which I think's maybe
the most impressive thing of all time
but yeah the pitches are stacked
different you know I almost feel bad for
some of the pictures that got drafted
there because you're not really like
playing on the same same game that we
are because it's just and why is it what
is it cuz the air is thinner so what
right so the ball can't like it as the
ball goes it'll move certain ways
because it gets air and you're spinning
it and it pulls it other ways there the
air is thinner so it doesn't pull it the
same way Oh interesting so if there's
less moisture in the air than there's
less for the ball to grip on moths in
the air yep
yeah so you can't do the same things
that you normally do or you have to try
and aim certain you know all season you
throw one pitch the same way to the same
area and it pretty much does what you
think it's going to do in there it'll
end up half moving half as much and
right in the middle and they just kill
you now what about um how do you pitch
so say you want a guy to hit a ball like
a ground ball like how do you powdi how
do you pitch to him typically you're
gonna throw a lower okay higher means
ground balls or higher means fly balls
lower means ground balls typically know
obviously the scouting and all that
stuff and kind of the research that we
do so certain guys really can hit the
ball low and whatever but typically
you're gonna aim lower yeah a big thing
do you guys is there a lot of like do
you feel like there's good team unity as
as much team unity as you've gone up
through the ranks because you did you
play some at triple-a for some yeah so
you play in the minor leagues and that's
like the toughest thing to actually have
like a cohesive team because every week
that team has two or three guys that
they didn't the week before everyone's
he got to be super selfish in the minor
leagues you try not act like it but 95
percent of your thoughts are about how
good you're doing
once you get to the big league is about
winning yeah so yeah and the big leagues
is where you kind of come together more
but at the same time you've got guys
that are making crazy money and live in
a completely different life than you and
your if you're making the league minimum
some guys are making twenty five thirty
million dollars you're just gonna live
differently you know what I mean yeah
the other thing I think that's hard
about LA is none of us live near each
other I think you're playing Cincinnati
you're gonna live in two or three little
neighborhoods their neighborhood yeah
and you can go have a barbecue on off
days and stuff like that' and we try and
do it but for me to go to Kirsch's house
from marina last year it was hour and a
half well yeah so it's hard to do that
kind of stuff I think but I think inside
of our Clubhouse all of us are pretty
close is there a sport that you guys
compete in off outside of baseball we
play a lot of cards oh really yeah
yeah I've kind of a swimming you know in
some other waters yeah and then playing
against guys that are making real real
money and not that like we don't make
enough money but comparatively right so
you could just get bullied and and lose
our money but so she doesn't meet up and
do some poker games or stuff like that
and the flights most the time right
that's like the big past the time on the
flights thing is we play poker is it
just poker you uh play rummy gin any
things we used to play a game called
three five seven which is per my
personal favorite and what screwed me is
I won a lot of money playing that game
because you and so then I had to stay in
the poker games or else I was like the
[ __ ] that won the money and then
bounced Yeah right so we're playing this
other game and then this was my rook
here we got some new guys on the team at
the trade deadline they're like no no no
we're playing poker all right and I just
lost but I'd rather lose it then be the
guy that ran away I think yeah still not
fun what were some other things going up
in the egg going into those minor
leagues and being in that vibe where
it's uh like are the things that you
miss about that a little bit yeah I mean
Sharon you used to share like a
two-bedroom apartment for guys you know
it's just like it sucks it's not perfect
but it's kind of fun at times I think
you know everybody rolls the field
together goes home kind of it's fun to
have people to clown around with yeah
just mess around with that for games
especially because your first time at my
leisure not making no money you're
making it $1,200 a month really oh yeah
so you're making yeah you're talking
taxes you're kidding like 400 bucks
maybe every two weeks and that's only
for seven months of the year six months
of the year then we don't get paid in
the offseason so yeah you're just
splitting and kind of an EMC almost a
lot of these guys have to have somebody
to bankroll a moment there or you got a
really share share places yeah I know a
lot of guys who get jobs all offseason
and then try and train and whatever but
that's that's where the luxury being
picked on the draft is you get this
little bonus that you know kind of sets
you up to where you can live and just
train and get ready to get to the big
leagues I think but what what do you
think the dismantling of that like this
season they didn't have it you know they
didn't have the minors and I don't even
know I'm not sure if those guys are
still getting paid maybe they all got
little stipends I think would that be
tough to say like if you two gone
through that I mean do you right what
would that have been like you think you
still would have been pitching are later
yeah I mean I think I would have played
out as I said I was really fortunate to
have kind of a little nest egg - oh yeah
that's right look you hadn't had that
you know right I think it's very tough I
think those guys and the other thing
that sucks about that is they do there's
no clue if if and when they were gonna
play so it's not like you can walk into
Lululemon and get a job and say hey you
know I can be here for a year where I
can be here for six months you have to
say listen I'd love to have a job but
but I'm gone three weeks you know so
that's where I was pretty financially
tough and David Price who we just traded
for from the Red Sox came out really
gave all of our minor leaguers like a
thousand bucks
June which is just super super cool it's
really nice just to kind of help guys
try and stay afloat during this whole
thing
yeah and just set up that support that
other people are thinking about you like
hey you know somebody else is thinking
about what's going on with you yeah he's
he's never played a game for us we just
got him and he still did that for our
guys which which I think was really
really cool and and some other guys have
done similar stuff and you know some
teams have committed to playing they're
paying that stipend for awhile and but I
you know I don't think minor league
baseball will ever ever look the same
because you're thinking
like we have a lo a team in the city I'm
from in Lexington that was on the list
to be chopped
yeah before all this little hone after
so Lao
you know these tiny small towns that's
there's just not that many people so
it's hard to hard to own a baseball team
in rural Iowa you know but it's a bummer
to cuz then the kid the kids that were
gonna go there and watch the game who
are then like oh I want to play this you
know who were finding that you know
filling that space in their head where
inspiration Luis aren't gonna have that
right less less chances and you know
you're not gonna I don't think you'll
have as many kind of Cinderella sort
like you talk about Mike Piazza he was
like the last round pick or whatever
well I read his book I forget what round
was back then they had like 70 round
he's a 65th round last slice of Piazza I
think was that's horrible but obviously
we tell some pretty bad here oh man I
was gonna ask you about Rudy start
wondering about the minor leagues you
you do a golf tournament is that what
you do I do
as a geyser yeah so we did our second
second one this past year which is
pretty cool the first year I had an
uncle passed away from kind of long-term
complications of child pediatric cancer
so he beat it and passed away at like 42
hey young huh yeah he dad's brother yeah
he's my dad's older brother he beat
Hodgins at like 13 or 12 but you know
back then the 87 City know what they
were doing they were just kind of trying
to say back when they put you on a jar
murmur they put a picture on a jar and
just yeah they just see what happens
that was the original like Facebook
share dude they would put a picture on a
jar and set it at the pizza place yeah
and raise money yeah but no so he he
passed away so we did the first year for
that we raised like $37,000 which was
awesome which was cool and we were so
excited and then Rich Hill who played
with us last couple years started a
foundation called Field of jeans which
didn't know much about we kind of talked
a lot he and I ended up becoming really
close and talked about he had lost a son
which was [ __ ] devastating obviously
we you know I told our whole team story
and so this past year we did it for his
his new initiative and where he's 100
grand this year which was really really
cool it's cool
so yeah I mean you know I think everyone
does a to the golf tournament right but
it is really fun and cool and I think
we're doing some good stuff yeah ya know
it sounds like it man that's brave of
him to even wanna rent room you know
memorialize that I think even
memorialize and things can be kind of
break because you have to go through
that some turbulence and stuff yeah you
know he was super emotional about it
obviously and I spoke at the event and
stuff and people were just like all
right let's we're buying all this [ __ ]
and we're in yeah and obviously you know
the city of Lexington being from there
is pretty close-knit and really cool
city man yeah I love it it's you know a
lot of southern cities to get a bit get
a rough wrap everybody especially right
now everybody you know the news wants to
make the South look kind of bad
sometimes I feel like and that stuff
really makes me mad because there's some
amazing cities there man Lexington is
one of them it's super diverse you get
down to the university man it's so much
fun the strangest people dude I've had
some of the strangest times I saw a guy
I took I do I do the worm all the way
around the a four way warm Eddie yeah
look it look like he had some miles on
his belly
you know calluses oh really yeah he was
calloused around the belly button no I
was gonna
oh so one time I got invited I used to
work as a tour manager for this guy Josh
Kelly who was a music who is a musician
and he and his brother were both
musicians and they had a golf tournament
because his brother works in that band
Lady Antebellum and I got to stay in a
they put us up it was in Augusta Georgia
and they put us up in different you know
and Ozzie Smith was in mine mm-hmm which
was really really cool man Chris Dolman
was in there he used to play for
Minnesota this a little bit for your
time Jim Furyk was in there golfer me up
and and it was me and that guy Dan
member Dave versus Dan for the Olympics
or whatever you were probably too young
well but it was like date
Dan versus danvers' day
Danya yeah they're both him remembers
well yeah you have this in this before
that yeah this back when uh when it was
just man versus man dude when man was
less lonely and now it says man vs. wild
like the Calphalon guys yes yes the
Catholic guys and this was huge and I
was a kid they were boat supposed to go
to the Olympics and I think one of them
didn't qualify and so that was like the
big bummer yeah Dan vs. Dade can you
find it on Wikipedia - thanks bud and
advertising the campaign is a television
commercials O'Brien and Johnson were
favored to win medals in Barcelona which
had recently lost US market share to
Nike was hoping to rebound with their
endorsement did when arrived five weeks
before the games began when O'Brien
failed to qualify for the American
Olympic team by missing the pole vault
huh damn
yeah dude so the Hall of America's fired
up for them to go to the Olympics while
and it didn't go the this was where he's
at now well so my my Olympics story the
first guy or this spring first spring
training I got to play golf with Michael
Phelps which was no way the coolest at
long belly huh hey Mike dude he looks
real he's like a damn pine looks like a
fish for the face nothing really
no but you just see him swimming yeah
I'm telling you that guy's golf I've
never seen so many shoulders so he wraps
he's done that golf it was awesome cool
dude yeah it was fun dang that's pretty
cool man
now golf tournaments I will say one
thing that's amazing about him is the
people you get to meet at him yeah
there's a lot that one in Phoenix is
crazy apparently I still haven't gone
that what is it the way the waste
management oh no it's a PG that's the
one they have the whole word buddy
screams and yells oh wow have you never
seen this oh that's oh Michael yes see
that's at waste management because he
lives in Arizona I think yeah put up
this I think it's a 17th hole waste
management or whatever or type in waste
management and it was Michael Ehrlich no
no just put up the waste management
I think it is a 17th hole yeah so this
is the only thing in golf like this 16th
hole they built up this giant stadium
all around this hole and people can yell
the whole time
the I think this is Ricky Fowler he's
like pumping up the crowd it's the only
place in golf and they just scream the
whole time I really did see that guy in
the Jersey yes John Romney played at
Arizona State so it's like his home city
you know huh he's from Spain till he's
fired up and so he's wearing a he's
wearing a ASU uni damn Rickie Fowler's
damn beautiful for a damn golfer huh
that's jordan Spieth how it is sorry
Ricky
oh that ain't met and so this is a part
three huh yeah it's like a little short
there's Ricky right there in the gray so
they play so people can yell her and
there's Donald Trump jr. as the caddie
do you see that Trump son looks like the
caddie right there with that it looked
like him a little bit but on it's like
it's like damn club in Vegas around this
place they say it's wild wow it's in
Phoenix in like early February I think
huh and so they got a little quiet for
when the action will hit but there was
still a lot of chatter usually dead
quiet type in Ricky Fowler cuz he
there's one where he full-on like pumps
up the crowd gets the ball and he's like
it's too quiet and he steps back and
starts screaming at him place the crowd
there you go yeah there you go
[Applause]
oh I'd be so nervous ro look at the
character sign he's usually telling
people to be quiet
[Music]
Wow point they're just screaming are you
any are you any good
well alright yeah okay I did a little
lesson yesterday we're working on the
game okay
we're working on are there any things
about pitching that you correlate over
to golf that that help your you know
what I think playing baseball and hang
golf are actually like you have the
basic like you can rotate your hips
quick and so most of us can hit the ball
pretty far but in baseball and golf your
work your legs work completely different
so we all have bad swings even if they
look alright because our legs don't lie
operate the way they should I think is
the biggest thing like hitters don't
really play golf much because they feel
like it's gonna mess with their swing so
I came here when we were growing up like
in high school they bag I'm gonna play
golf I know you're not you have a game
tomorrow right you can't mess up your
swing right don't be thinking about
slope plays right yeah huh
um trying to think of anything else man
you got anything new
mm-hm I was curious this is just small
who is the armored arbitrator is it
someone who play baseball agent the
arbiter arbitrator our head guy yeah so
the head of the union's name is Tony
Clark he had a pretty successful like a
really successful career in the big
leagues and then we have like his help
not the helpers not the right word I
don't know his official title his name's
Bruce Meyer he helped with the NBA CBA
with the NFL CBA she's professional
arvid there's a professional
professional
yeah but the head guy the guy that comes
out and speaks that you've heard him
comment was a player Tony Clark yep so
you know we have some interesting stuff
we have big group phone calls and kind
of talked through some stuff and wow
that's totally do I mean it seems like
you're kind of [ __ ] growing up a
little dude you know trying man I got
engaged and
and then no you got a second although
second dog
you know we had Nala for about a year in
all his day off 21 is her Instagram the
new one barrel doesn't have one yet but
he's my Allah's day off in all his day
off 21 and then barrel Bueller will be
the new one yeah we don't know what
we're gonna do he's a Boykin so Beryl
Bueller the Boykin kind of works mm and
a Boykin is what is it
it's like a small cocker spaniel but
they're all brown they all look exactly
the same okay
he'll be about thirty pounds but I
wanted a hunting dog I do a little bit
of duck hunting here and there mmm so we
we got that one cuz it's the smallest
one you can get that can really go do
that stuff but also small enough for my
fiance to travel with a little bit okay
so she likes the dog too yeah she she is
absolutely obsessed with the first dog
Nala our little our little french
bulldog
okay yeah yeah we got that one opening
day last year so oh that's cool
yeah then we drove down and we get one
each year you think you're know I think
this is it for a while two twos kind of
you know people told us that that
puppies are harder than kids and and I
some upheaval yeah our first kid or our
first dog was kind of easy and all it
was like pretty good this other one just
pissed set everywhere he's tough but
anarchist sounds like a drunk friend
yeah they're they're tough you know but
then I just left him in at home with
McKenzie so she's oh they're in Kentucky
right now well you get to go back at
home and all during this stretch know
she'll come out here okay here she
usually does about half the half the
season I don't know what we're gonna do
this year we had it all planned out but
obviously that got changed up a little
bit so yeah we'll figure it out
and you think you'll go ahead to head
with Jo Musgrove this year or not no we
won't play them licensed in the playoffs
because they're in the East so normally
we would we played he pitched against us
last year who do you have an arch rival
out there that you love to pitch against
me you said clarity but uh not a single
guy I think for us is more teams
obviously the Giants are big and you
know the Rockies have some a lot of
talent over there so playing them is
always a big deal but that stuff happens
more in your division I think than
anything is it fun to play against uh is
it fun to play against teams
have you want teams that have a lot of
good hitters or do you are you better if
teams are kind of I mean I'd rather face
your little league team yeah then team
the club's yeah in all honesty but no I
mean I think I think it's good stuff
when you're trying to get ready for the
playoffs and things like that when he
faced these good teams and get used to
all right like these guys could
legitimately kill me not kill me but
crush me you know so you know it takes a
little something to get get ready to get
go like that yeah what we're gonna say
about Charlie Blackmon I think we kind
of went off on that you have the same
hair and he's the hardest hitter to well
he's he has he's had the most success
off me in the big leagues ever ham so
there's there's a you know there's a
little bit of then power yeah power flow
what do you attribute it to is there
anything about him specifically that you
noticed you know I think as we Scout you
learn like oh this guy hits this pitch
really good and this pitch really bad
and things like that and you know my
strengths as a pitcher what I can do
best it's kind of his strengths a lot of
times you you know you want to stay with
your strengths unless a guy has a
glaring weakness and he doesn't have any
glaring ones so I just kind of have to
go with what I do well and he happens to
handle it pretty well mm-hmm but there's
just bad matchups and good matchups
there's really good hitters that just I
match up well against or a really bad
hitters you know against most people
that still get do really well against me
that just that's that's what baseball's
kind of a weird game in that way I think
what about bonkers do you guys hate it I
think it's it seems dumb but is it dumb
is this you know you guys are is what's
weird about that is one of God bunts
like that's our only chance like kind of
look athletic and when it's happening
you feel so athletic do you really oh my
god you sprint off grab and throw it and
then I see it on replay
and I run like an idiot yeah really yeah
everybody gives me [ __ ] about how our
what's going on
is it mechanics what is it yeah I got
bad hips yeah oh you might have
dysplasia like my buddy Scott's
Australian Shepherd yeah it's I bet that
that athletic shepherd still runs way
better than I do
and Walker Buehler thanks so much for
joining us it was fun man yeah I
appreciate you best of luck dude
congrats on you know that was your first
all-star season right yep Wow man you
know see if they can you know I don't
know if you're gonna be able to come to
any games well see feel pretty some
tickets I could just send them to your
house yeah I'll just have dude I might
go in a shower cut out yeah we might
have to do that
or what's in my calendar Wilson Nick it
will give him a day off well good what
we'll do is we'll get some some
everybody's a find some bad photos of
them just a minute oh you know fine if
we paid for Brian and printing with just
some horrible pictures of them yeah
which are a lot of their pictures
we really should that would be so good I
guess
Brian just got his eyes done part of his
eyes sending the picture of him all
swelled up yeah that's a good idea maybe
we'll do a little fundraiser or
something and we'll buy that and then
we'll donate the rest to uh to your
charity or something like it'd be
awesome
yeah do that of him and maybe Schaub
after he got knocked out or something
yeah I agree with you a hundred percent
bro oh dude I went to more TFE antenna
two forty how it take him I have to gain
60 pounds but I could do it bro I might
have to meet these guys before we do it
maybe that's what I'll meet them and
then we'll reveal in the next there we
go if we get it done man we'll have to
get you over on the fighter in the
carrying off to be fine touch base with
the man up obviously I had a good time
enjoy good to see you yeah you too man
and thanks for yeah you took me out to
the game last year man it was a lot of
fun I got to bring my friend Steve dude
we had a blast we sat right behind
Kershaw's family actually yeah yeah good
people - yeah it was it was nice over
there best of luck man thanks man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
can lift myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with a heavy level
[Music]
and these whales that are been robbed
know that wants to build a dam name
[Music]